all right so you want to get into Tech
but you see all these generative AI
tools that are spitting out code now and
you're thinking is my future over before
it even started right what am I going to
do okay first thing don't lose heart AI
is not taking away the need for software
Engineers if anything I believe it's
actually going to create more
opportunities as it speeds up the
industry what have we been yelling for
years learn to code right and I think
we're going to need even more people who
can read and write and understand code
now that we have ai lowering the barrier
to entry to spit out all this code and
config somebody's going to have to debug
that stuff and Harden it operate it in
production that person could be you
second thing get comfortable using AI as
a force multiplier if they won't let you
use in your classes yet go create some
side projects you will still learn the
code by doing that because you're going
to have to tweak and correct anything
the AI spits out finally the best career
defense against AI is being a
well-rounded human being a technical
person who can talk to people who can
solve business problems that's always
been a unicorn even more so now so don't
just be a programmer be a problem solver
those are always in demand